hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the young tragedy and Agathon is going
to give a speech almost at the end of
all the speeches at the symposium it's
supposed to be the second to last
although it turns out to be the third to
last in which he is going to praise love
and he says that everybody else has sort
of fallen down on the job they haven't
actually managed to praise love now he
is going to do it the right way he's
going to give this very well-crafted
rhetorically structured speech which
contains an argumentative structure in
including you know making a central
claim and then providing backing for
that claim through a number of Sabha
arguments now he was doing so in such a
way that that you can't automatically
view them as arguments because he's such
a great writer interestingly enough he's
not going to give a tragic speech or
anything reflecting his his skill as at
radik tragedian rather he is going to
get of a speech that shows that he can
really put together rhetorically crafted
speeches so there's two main arguments
two main claims that are being given one
is a love is in
the loveliest or the most beautiful of
the Gods so love is the the most Kalos
the most fine the most noble and the
other is going to be that love it is the
best morally speaking so we've got the
two sides of Cologne and Agathon that go
along with this it's also reflected in
his name which turns out to be a happy
coincidence by the way and there's four
main lines of argument that he's going
to give to make this assertion that love
is in fact the loveliest are the most
beautiful of the Gods he's going to
begin by talking about love beating the
youngest of the gods now when you when
you see these arguments try to
appreciate first that he's actually
providing an argument and then thinking
about whether these are actually good
arguments or where the counter examples
can be given and remember that this is
given in the middle of a flowing speech
in which there's you know a continuous
you know flow of rhetoric going on so
the audience members can't be expected
to say you know hold their hands up and
say well what about this there are a few
places where you can point out some
problems with this youngest also with
the most delicate and so forth well
let's see where he's going he says love
runs away from time from the ravages of
time from the age what does he mean by
that
he means that as people age they become
less lovely doesn't mean that they love
less it means that love is not being
directed towards them instead long
prefers that which is similar to him as
a god that is youths the the he's
eternally young and so he prefers young
people and you know we see something
like this with the whole notion of
trophy wives or I suppose trophy
husbands there's another name for it
that's a little bit boy toys where older
people who are now successful through
over there mate who's no longer as
physically attractive in part because
they're not as young and youth is
identified
physical attractiveness even though you
know it's rather arbitrary thing this is
you know what goes on in our time it was
also going on at the time of the Greeks
and there was this sense that you know
as age takes its toll one becomes less
beautiful less lovely less capable of
being the object of attraction the
object of eros the other thing that he
says which is quite interesting as a
mythological justification he says long
as the youngest of the gods because
clearly if he loved was on the scene all
these other things that happen in these
stories which aren't really all that
believable anyway but let's just assume
for the moment that they are all these
things that the gods and the Titans did
wouldn't have really happened you know
that was under the realm of necessity of
compulsion what does he mean by this
well he gives a few examples you know a
prime example of this is Kronos
castrating his father ordering us and
taking power this is the reign of the
Titans the before the the Olympian gods
who knows is one of the first of the
gods and gain a earth almost mean sky
game means earth they they mate and they
bring forth the Titans and some of these
things are just monsters you know like
the hundred handed ones or the cyclopses
you know Prometheus Epimetheus they're
not that bad all Epimetheus is kind of a
dumb guy but Kronos actually takes
charge by not only deposing his father
but by castrating him he throws the you
know the the remnants of what he's cut
off into the sea that's where Aphrodite
comes out in the olden Aphrodite story
that we saw with Polonius so this is not
nice stuff but then Kronos himself if
you know that the story about the Greek
gods he swallows all of his children as
they are born Zeus gets away because his
mother Rhea has crossed his wife and by
this time is totally sick of seeing all
of her children eaten up by their father
so so what he does or what she does is
takes a rock
puts it in the you know the baby clothes
and he swallows the whole thing up and
he thinks that he's got you know his
baby taken care of meanwhile these kids
are living in his belly for a long time
Zeus grows up gets him to throw up all
these other gods like his brothers Hades
and Poseidon and his sisters you know
Hestia dem matter and and Hera and
there's a war between the Titans and the
guys you get the point right lots of
conflict
lots of bloodshed lots of craziness
going on if love was around
Agathon argues none of this would have
happened why not everyone would have
gotten along because that's what love
does so those are the two things
supporting that love is the youngest of
the guys that Niko's RA says what's more
love is the most delicate it's the most
Monaco's in it or it has the most of the
greatest degree of Molossia in the Greek
which by the way is going to come to me
in weakness or or vice later on with
people like like Aristotle but in this
case he's talking about it in terms of
delicacy in terms of a you know being
being what we would say you know
precious in a way and how do we know
this is the case well again he resorts
to a mythological reference he says that
that love actually avoids whatever is
harder rough so love doesn't step on the
ground for example you know walking on
gravel or anything like that and I'm
like aw a the goddess of destruction who
is so dainty that she walks on the heads
of mortals love walks on something
that's even softer cos heads are kind of
hard right anytime you like bang your
head against somebody else you know
that's the case love walks on the soul
or it's translated in some the hearts of
men and gods because this is the softest
part of us yeah so that's how we know
that love is the most delicate love is
the most dainty of dwells in us in the
parts of us that are not hard this
actually kind of fits in well with this
notion of love being supple love being
flexible love being able to get in the
nooks and crannies love avoids the hard
things but it can go around the hard
things and get into the softness of the
soul and the evidence that he provides
in the middle of the speech for this
this suppleness of love is several
different points he says love turns us
in endless convolutions it spins us
around right you think about what it's
like to be infatuated with somebody that
makes some good sense love gets us to do
some crazy things
that's pretty metaphorical language and
then he talks about love entering into
our souls secretly without us actually
knowing it this is a sign that love
really does have we might say the
dexterity to get through all of the
obstacles that are set up so the person
you know we've all seen these of these
movies or TV shows or plays where
somebody says I'm not going to fall in
love with anybody I'm writing off men or
women forever you know just gonna
concentrate on work what's the first
thing that happens of course they meet
somebody and love sneaks in despite
their best efforts to keep it at bay
well that's because love can enter into
our souls secretly it can also leave
when he chooses we can't control love we
can't make a prison of our hearts and
keep him within there let me also talks
about loves elegance and that's way in
of translating a you know a comp is a
Greek word and scam a new scam loosening
the molle today makes it something like
a attribute you know like a dko soon as
justice or so fro soon a is a temperance
it'll means good then the schema you
know we get the word schema from that
and a literal means like how things are
are
set up or or arrange so and it was same
those came out means like a goodness of
arrangement so we translate it with
elegance we might think about in terms
of grace being well put together is
another thing that we sometimes say we
don't have an exact translation for it
but it's one of those fuzzy Greek terms
that you know people probably meant
different things by it in any cases and
all let me write love it has this right
love is well set up so that means that
love is going to be most subtle why
would that lead to love being supple or
flexible well think about when the body
is you know well arranged and all the
parts are in their proper order that
allows you to be more flexible if you
get bones that are kind of out of joint
or something you lose what we call range
of motion you lose your flexibility so
all this supports love being more supple
it brings it to a close with these
interesting reflections on flowers you
know we tend to think of flowers as
being a romantic thing of you know the
modern period but no flowers were
associated with love throughout the you
know these developments of culture
including back in the ancient world so
he talks about loves beauty of color
beauty of hue beauty of shade something
that's actually in many respects quite
physical alright quite sensuous and he
says wherever flowers are found or we
know the scent the odor of flowers so
imagine you know you could also think of
perfume as well and unguents and stuff
like that their love is going to be
found and where things are you know old
and decaying and rotten there won't be
any love there because there's no
loveliness there so the love is
attracted to what's growing to what
ripening to what is even just budding
what is coming forth this would partly
be why long prefers the young because
the young are so to speak all potential
right there on the surface you know
waiting to come up not like say you know
45 year old body which has you know
wrinkles and you know your ears keep
growing and your nose keeps growing all
these sorts of things that we talk about
right that's mature state and then we
have our bodily senescence as well
long avoids that sort of thing love
doesn't like the old people love likes
in both people and in nature what is
either at its peak or on its way to its
peak so all these are reasons that
Agathon is giving for why love is the
loveliest or the most beautiful of all
of the gods